[Musik]
große schiffe raus aus der lagune rufen
sie in kleinen boten die protestierenden
wollen eine rückkehr der
kreuzfahrtschiffe nach venedig
verhindern
auch martha so tory war demonstriert für
ihre stadt initialen teilt die sorge der
initiative no grandi navi
die schiffe würden der umwelt in der
lagune und der bausubstanz der
weltkulturerbestadt schaden
[Musik]
wir sind gegen ein tourismuskonzept dass
die städte zerstört und einwohner aus
ihren wohnungen vertreibt die hier
einfach nur leben wollen
nach mehr als anderthalb jahren sticht
die msi orchester von venedig aus zur
mittelmeer kreuzfahrt in see
laut reederei solle das schiff bis mitte
oktober jeden samstag hier anlegen
venedigs start und zielhafen der adria
kreuzfahrten hierher verirren sich die
touristen dagegen kaum wir treffen marta
in ihrem stadtteil wieder die 29-jährige
ist lehrerin bei ihr gehalt keine großen
mietzahlungen möglich macht teilt sie
sich die wg mit einem mitbewohner das
alltägliche leben in venedig ist teuer
immer mehr menschen sind weggezogen
erzählt sie die pandemie habe das
schonungslos offengelegt
[Musik]
eine stadt wie venedig ist leer ohne
touristen
das bedeutet dass viele anwohner in den
letzten 30 40 jahren vertrieben wurden
es ist keine geisterstadt sondern eine
stadt am rande des zusammenbruchs
die plätze ohne kinder die spielen ohne
jugendliche die um die häuser ziehen
geschlossene schaufenster von geschäften
die schritt für schritt zum verkauf oder
zur miete angeboten werden
es war keine stadt die wegen der
pandemie geschlossen wurde
es ist eine stadt die aufgehört hat zu
leben
doch nach den millionenverlusten durch
die korona krise sind bei weitem nicht
alle venezianer gegen den
kreuzfahrttourismus den
geschäftstreibenden steht das wasser bis
zum hals in erster linie sind die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen in venedig
enorm aber die andere sache ist dass
wenn wir dich von der reiseroute
gestrichen würde
die konsequenzen für die adria reisen
sehr groß wären
die kreuzfahrttouristen spülten geld in
die lagune viel geld und viele
venezianer sind über die jahre immer
abhängiger geworden vom massentourismus
für mich sind die kreuzfahrtschiffe in
ordnung sie bringen einen haufen leute
5000 6000 arbeitsplätze sind nicht
wenige verbindet sie schaden der lagune
ohne frage aber die schiffe sind gut für
die wirtschaft der stadt die sich seit
über 30 jahren an den tourismus verkauft
hat da gibt es kein zurück mehr
bei der auseinandersetzung in venedig
geht es auch um den tourismus der
zukunft marta und ihre mitstreiterinnen
befürchten das aus gier der
massentourismus zurückkehre
dabei habe die korona zwangspause doch
allen vor augen geführt wie gestresst
städte wie venedig durch den
massentourismus waren die regierung in
rom hatte im frühjahr versprochen
alternativen für den kreuzfahrttourismus
in venedig zu suchen mit einem
ideenwettbewerb das ist den protestieren
am canal grande deutlich zu wenig
unterstützung haben sie gerade von einer
vielzahl prominenter bekommen auch mit
jagger der gerne nach venedig kommt wie
hier vor zwei jahren zum film festival
hat einen offenen brief an den
italienischen staatspräsidenten und die
regierung draghi unterschrieben die
bedrohte lagunenstadt solle endlich
besser geschützt werden
wenn es um venedig geht gibt es eine
prominente stimme die nicht erst jetzt
zu hören ist bestseller autorin donna
leon die venedig mit ihrem commissario
brunetti ein ganz eigenes literarisches
denkmal gesetzt hat
ich erreiche donna leon in zürich die
ist entschieden gegen den maritimen
massentourismus in venedig ich denke das
hauptproblem ist der schaden der
unglaubliche schaden den die schiffe der
substanz der stadt antun der bausubstanz
dieser stadt vor der pandemie kamen pro
saison über 500 kreuzfahrtschiffe in die
lagune
das bedeutete mehr als 1000 durch
fahrten pro jahr und millionen
tagestouristen venedig diese fragile
schatzkammer deren lagune vom
klimawandel bedroht ist mit ihr leidet
etwas ganz wichtiges die
verantwortlichkeit meint donna leon
ich glaube dass viele menschen immer
neue dinge begehren ohne über die
konsequenzen ihres handelns nachzudenken
und ich bin hier nicht predigen aber ich
denke massentourismus ist ein perfektes
beispiel dafür dass menschen etwas
begehren ohne daran zu denken zu wessen
lasten das geht ohne daran zu denken wer
den preis dafür bezahlt hat mir extra
dieses foto geschickt weil sie
beeindruckt ist von den couragierten
frauen die gerade für venedigs zukunft
kämpfen
auch ihre freundin jane wir brauchen
schiffe die erneuerbare energien nutzen
wir brauchen schiffe die nicht tausende
von menschen auf einmal in unsere engen
gassen bringen wir brauchen besucher die
sich für venedig interessieren
es ist eine stadt die wir uns stück für
stück wieder zurückholen müssen
es ist eine stadt für die man kämpfen
muss und dass es die einzige möglichkeit
um sich hier eine zukunft vorstellen zu
können
wem venedig ernsthaft am herzen liege so
hoffen sie wird alters bedenken ein
weiter so wird es mit diesen starken
frauen der lagunenstadt wohl eher nicht
geben
der venezianische löwe danach sieht es
aus ist eine löwin